russia says that the strike was directed
at military officials who were meeting
in in a particular building in in this
city
is that is that likely are they trying
to cover their tracks was their
intelligence wrong perhaps um it's
difficult to say whether their
intelligence is wrong um we will
probably never know whether the
intelligence is accurate or whether
actually just working it as an excuse
for the justifying the attack what it
does tell me though is that their whole
intelligence process and subsequent
targeting process
there's an irresponsible approach or a
flawed approach to how they do that and
from my own experiences whenever we were
planning um strategic attacks such as
this in my previous career the
intelligence would always be
corroborated with other sources we would
never rely on a single source reporting
to actually work against an intelligence
target and there'll be so much work then
done in the targeting building up that
target profile the reason behind it the
justification for carrying out that
attack
and the the most suitable weapon system
that we would use to actually prosecute
that target um we would then go on to
the whole targeting process which would
eventually lead to uh the the legal guys
that the people that are experiencing
legal matters to actually look at it see
if it fits in with the rules engagements
most important thing is looking at the
the potential for collateral damage if
there's any potential for collateral
damage at all then we would have to
rework it it looks to me like the
russians are paying lip service that
kind of process um they're getting a
some form of intelligence which
isn't really backed up or corroborated
they're not paying any attention to the
classical damage that could be happening
as a result of their attack and they're
just going ahead and conducting those
attacks is that a surprise though i mean
do we think of russia as always
following the rules to the letter as it
sounds like uh you did and the british
perhaps continue to do well i can talk
for for all the nato countries we know
we have that strict rigorous legal
process that we have to go through for
the russians it seems to be they do seem
to have a little bit more responsible
there they're very much a kinetic force
very much an offensive force um the
actual way that they use their
intelligence to me it seems a little bit
blase
let's also talk about uh the town of
saverska that apparently russia has
seized and captured is that uh a very
significant place
so at the moment the russians um it was
announced by president putin there on a
uh an operational pause after securing
uh the litter chance city um earlier on
in the month and obviously securing the
whole of the the hands go blast the next
um logical phase of their campaign would
be the move into donetsk itself and
saversk is probably one of the key
places where they can go to now the
russians are claiming that they have um
taken subversion it's been
uncorroborated so far we haven't got any
confirmation of that what we have been
seeing is uh increased and intense
artillery bombardment uh of slavansk
down to bachmate itself and the tanner
saversk um the russians do do artillery
very very well it's one of the things
that they they pay a lot of them
attention to doing um it would make
sense them to actually moving into
subversion i think it's no this could be
the the precursor for a more uh
sustained offensive into the united
states which is obviously part of their
their the campaign to seize the donbass
region as a whole um
it does move towards the the e40 highway
which runs down from slovansk down to
backmark which is a key highway that
they will need to secure that's that's
that's going to stop the ukraine
defenders from having more freedom of
movement in that area to move troops
around to where they're acquired and
also to where they need to get the um
the army ammunition and equipment